Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still
blazing a trail
for those who take
their fate into their own hands
by working hard...
Introducing BatBnB.
‐Blood‐sucking bats.
‐[ Gasps ]
...by working smart...
This is called
the CoyoteZapper.
[ Dog barks ]
Grr. Aah!
[ Laughter ]
...by thinking big...
Armenti: Not only do we serve
your favorite foods,
but we do it all
on one sandwich.
‐No!
‐Yes!
...and chasing their dreams.
All I need are my
black‐belt business partners.
Greiner:
My God. Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
So, Sharks,
who's ready to dig in?
I feel the big one!
I feel the big one coming!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a dual‐purpose product
with convenience in mind.
♪♪
Greetings, Sharks.
I'm Rener Gracie,
and I'm seeking
a $500,000 investment
in exchange for
a 5% equity stake
in my apparel company Quikflip.
Ooh.
It was a cold
December morning...
[ Chuckles ]
...and my son wanted
to go to the park.
So I threw on
my favorite hoodie,
and off we went.
After about 30 minutes
of chasing this guy
around the park, the sun began
peeking through the clouds,
and I started to sweat.
At that point,
I had no choice
but to take off my hoodie.
You can probably guess
what my options were.
We have the fanny pack.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐We have the...
European yacht club.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I see you, Robert.
‐What?
‐And then we have the ‐‐
And then we have
the wannabe cool guy.
This is the option
I stuck with.
But when I finally caught up
to Little Man,
I bent over to pick him up,
and the hoodie
slipped off my shoulder
onto the wet grass.
‐Oh, no!
‐Ohh!
There has to be a better way!
‐Sharks, Sharks,
that was it!
Quikflip was born.
Check this out.
Flip it,
tuck it,
shake it,
and voilà.
In a matter of seconds...
Greiner: No!
...using our proprietary
conversion technology...
[ Laughter ]
...we can turn any
outwear garment
into a fully functional
backpack in a flash.
With our slide‐and‐bite
technology,
you can adjust the pack
to keep it safe and secure
during literally
any activity.
Even jujitsu
with your brother.
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
But wait. There's more!
You can store anything you want
inside the backpack.
And when
the temperature drops,
simply reach in,
take out your stuff,
with one hand ‐‐
Sharks, count to 3.
All: 1, 2 ‐‐
Too late.
We're already back
to full hoodie functionality...
[ Laughter ]
...in a matter of seconds.
Do you want to us leave?
We can step out
of the room for you.
No, no, no, no.
All I need are my black‐belt
business partners
to help me
submit the ‐‐ uh ‐‐
...to help me submit
the outwear industry
and flip your investments
into black‐belt profits.
Who's with me?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Wow.
‐That was exhausting.
‐And my brother, Ryron Gracie.
Thanks for being here, brother.
We'll see you soon.
‐Bye, brother.
‐Rener, can we see it?
‐Now you can see your samples.
‐[ Laughs ] Thank you.
‐Ahh.
‐Mark, you're right here.
‐Yes, sir. Appreciate it, Rener.
‐Thank you.
‐Check it out, you guys.
‐No worries.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Very nice.
Everyone stand up,
please.
It's a conversion race.
Put your stuff down.
So, here's the deal, guys.
All you do is you reach in,
grab the entire hoodie,
and pull it through,
and then just start
shoving the rest of it
on the inside.
Yes, reach in,
grab, and pull.
Everything,
you just grab and pull.
And then tuck it through
the inside, and then ‐‐
‐Bah‐bam!
‐Winner. Winner over there!
‐Yes!
‐I'm last.
‐Look at that.
So, you flip it on,
and then you grab the rope,
and you literally slide
and bite at any height.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Look, look, look. Look, look.
‐Ohh.
‐Slide and bite at any height.
Slide it up to any height.
And to loosen it, watch,
you just do this. Lookit.
Whoop. It comes right off.
‐Is this your first product?
‐Yeah. Have a seat, you guys.
Let's talk.
[ Laughter ]
So, here's the deal.
Tell us about you,
your background.
My grandfather, to kind of
give you a starting point,
was the co‐creator
of the art
of Brazilian jujitsu,
the now famous
all over the world,
fast‐growing martial art.
My father came to America
and started teaching
out of his garage in 1978.
It was my uncle Royce,
my dad's brother,
who went in UFC ‐‐
the early UFCs...
Oh. Right.
...went in there and beat these
giants, put us on the map.
And so the clothing brand
also came into fruition,
and we're selling T‐shirts,
hoodies, uniforms,
and martial‐arts apparel.
So we learned a lot of things
during this scaling of jujitsu.
A supply chain was
a critical factor there.
It's been incredibly helpful
to have those, too.
And what does
one of these cost?
We make them
for between $13 and $15.
We sell them for
between $40 and $50.
And how are you
selling them?
All of this has been
directly online.
We did, like, a pilot test.
We ordered 5,000 units,
put it out,
see how the people are gonna
respond to this.
And then, in 2 1/2 months,
we sold out.
So you sold $200,000 worth,
give or take?
Yeah, give or take.
But we started losing ‐‐
we started selling out
of our top SKUs,
like, within, you know, 60 days.
‐Okay, Rener, I get all that.
I want to hear
about sales now.
Are you always this
passionate and excited?
So, just real quick, it went
from a hoodie ‐‐ from a product,
as we, you know ‐‐ and I said ‐‐
‐We know this already.
So then, my wife's
mother says,
"Rener, I don't
wear hooded garments."
Guess what we came out with.
Convertible crew necks,
fully convertible.
Then parents called in and said,
"Hey, my kids always tell me
to carry their stuff."
Wait, wait.
Turn the crew neck around.
‐Yeah.
Oh, you have an entire
product line.
You guys,
this is not a product.
[ Singsong voice ]
It's a company.
We're here
to talk business.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that
what you guys like?
I've watched enough episodes.
‐Okay, so...
So, hold on.
I went to Disneyland, you guys,
and I saw
one dad carrying
six hoodies, jackets,
sweaters...
Oh, no.
...for all his daughters,
and I was like,
"No! This doesn't need
to be the case, you guys."
So...
So then we came out with
kids' variations, as well.
And then Costa Rica,
Hawaii, Miami,
and Seattle called.
And guess what they wanted.
Waterproof, you know, outerwear,
a little more durable.
We came up with the first
dry‐flip technology.
‐Rener, I got a ‐‐ I got a...
‐I got to see this!
‐Daymond, I got to see this.
‐Look at this ‐‐
the first dry‐flip technology.
You guys, you're out there,
it's raining.
And ‐‐ Kevin,
if you don't mind?
You're out there, it's raining.
‐Oh, no!
You're running, you're boom,
you're boom, you're boom.
All: No!
You're boom, you're boom,
you're boom.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐You're rain‐‐
I'm 100% dry in here,
no problem.
Look, this comes off.
Look. Look at this, you guys.
Costa Rica called.
‐"Costa Rica called"?
‐You shake it off,
and not only does it dry
100% on the inside,
but it turns into
a waterproof backpack.
‐Full dry‐flip technology.
‐Rener, Rener, I got a question.
Yes, sir?
Will we be able to talk
at all during the pitch?
‐Yes.
‐I'm just trying to get there.
Rener,
$500,000 for 5% ‐‐
imputes a $10 million value.
‐I feel you, Kevin.
‐So, give me some numbers!
‐You guys, it's so comfortable.
Greiner:
Mm‐hmm. [ Laughs ]
It's so comfortable
that I want to wear it.
[ Laughter ]
Rener,
it's gonna end badly
if you don't give me
some numbers.
So, here's the deal.
We did a little pilot launch.
It was great.
We sold out in 40 days
in the middle of the summer.
We do $279,000.
‐Got it.
‐And then in August alone,
we did $205,000 in sales.
‐So your total sales, $500,000.
‐Yeah, $577,000.
‐What did you make on that?
‐$220,000 profit, 38%,
all online,
direct to consumer.
Is there any way
that you can justify
the $10 million valuation
with $500,000 in sales?
I'm glad you guys asked.
So, the way
I look at Quikflip
is a potential
four‐legged monster.
Leg one ‐‐ direct to consumer,
which we love.
Step two ‐‐ the promotional
products industry.
Step three is gonna be
the licensing
of the technology...
‐Okay.
‐...to apparel companies.
And step four ‐‐
potentially retail.
I'm not dead‐set on it,
but with your guys' expertise...
Rener, do you have a propri‐‐
Is this proprietary?
Yes.
So, we have four patents ‐‐
uh, two utility
and two design patents
pending
domestically
and internationally.
Daymond, will he get
a patent for this?
He can, but I've had 50 patents
that I cannot protect
and/or they'll go around
and get a knock‐off.
So is your point
he can get patents, someone
will knock it off anyway?
Yeah. You know what?
And the reality is ‐‐
They will, and then you'll
just have to fight it,
which is expensive.
‐Yeah. We can speculate all day,
but one thing is for sure.
We can ‐‐ We can do a deal,
if we do one on the ‐‐
on the protection of the patent
and the intellectual property
being issued.
Rener, you're ‐‐ you're
crushing it right now.
Why do you need money?
‐The way we've been growing,
the inventory purchased,
uh, volume
has doubled every time
we've ordered.
Okay, so, here's my first
thought, Rener.
Yes.
I would just take
a backpack with me.
If this were the case, Mark ‐‐
I appreciate that.
I think if this were
the case for everybody,
I wouldn't have went
to Disneyland and saw
60 hoodies in a period of three
hours tied around people ‐‐
Rener, Rener,
it's not a question of whether
or not it's valid, right?
It is.
Your sales prove it.
I just don't see the connection
that we would create
or even any of
the Sharks, right?
'Cause you drive it
yourself.
For those reasons,
I'm out.
You know, I think it's great
what you're doing.
But a lot of these roads are not
gonna be successful for you,
and when you
send it to retail,
they can't tell what it is.
It's just another hoodie.
And the valuation
is way too high
for me to take
that road with you.
So I'm out.
Thank you. Um...
Rener, everybody agrees the
product probably has a market,
and you're a force of nature,
no question.
You're asking me
to pay 20 times sales.
Forget about profits.
That's crazy.
Classic deal where you
ask for too much money
at too early a time.
500K for this? You'd have
to have 50%, maybe more.
I'm out.
The power of this brand
is really ‐‐
it's a great idea, but it's you.
I mean, you are killing it.
You are the brand.
I want to be
in business with you.
But I give you $500,000,
just ‐‐ what do I ‐‐
‐Let me just ‐‐
‐Do I ‐‐ Do I submit you to 10%?
That's, you know, definitely
a conversation we can ‐‐
Absolutely.
I'm here to talk,
and I would love
to have a partner.
Like, I just ‐‐ I can't
structure the deal.
Is 10% good?
Now, let me just say about
our projections, Robert,
real quick, before you answer ‐‐
Uh, so, this year,
we're on set to do $1.2 million
before the end of the year.
Next year, we're estimated
to do $5.5 million.
The $500,000
is the problem.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll come back in.
Hear me on this.
Sure.
I'm structuring it.
I'll give you
$100,000 for 25%
and $400,000
as a line of credit.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐It's just debt.
So, half of his profits
for a quarter of his company.
I'll simplify
Kevin's deal.
He'll give you
$500,000 for 25%.
Forget how
he's structuring it.
Are you interested
in that deal?
If we were pre‐revenue,
I would consider 25%.
But because we have sales,
it would be unwise of me
to entertain 25%
at this current time.
It's an unknown.
It's an unknown of
what's that worth.
You know, I sit here,
and I always think
I have to do
what's right for me.
I think what's right
for me here...
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Rener has offers from Kevin
and Robert
for his convertible apparel
company Quikflip,
but Lori may be interested.
I think what's right
for me here...
♪♪
...is to make you
an offer.
I'm gonna
offer you $500,000
contingent on your getting
one of your patents,
and I'm gonna
do it for 15%.
This is beautiful, yeah.
Before we make a deal,
are there anybody else
who would like to entertain
some possibilities?
Wow.
She actually got you
to stop talking.
‐You should take that offer.
‐Oh, no, I'm thinking.
Trust me, I'm thinking.
‐You just need the right focus,
and you need my years of
experience and connections.
‐So, let me tell you something.
‐If you don't like my offer ‐‐
Instead ‐‐ Instead of
pushing for the patents ‐‐
Rener, my offer...
‐I don't put a lot of weight ‐‐
‐...might disappear.
I'll do the deal
for the 15% without...
But you need
to take my offer now.
...the contingencies
of patents.
I don't care
about your patents.
Lori, I have
a question for you.
If we went around the 10% mark,
but in your investment,
we did maybe
$300,000, uh, cash
and we did
$200,000 in a line of credit,
we're getting closer
to where I'm ‐‐
You said $300,000 ‐‐
$200,000 in
a line of credit...
Yeah. So, I'm willing
to split that up
so that you're not giving me
so much cash out the gate.
And $300,000 in cash.
‐Maybe $250,000 and $250,000.
‐But you want 10%,
but you're saying ‐‐
‐So, 10% equity ‐‐
10% equity
is where I'm at.
$250,000 and $250,000
and I'll do it.
♪♪
‐But you got to take it now.
‐Let me add a little confusion.
I like that. I like
the sound of that a lot.
If you're considering
between me and Kevin...
I'm not talking
to Kevin right now.
I'm talking to you, Lori.
‐[ Cuban laughs ]
‐Very good man.
‐Do you want to talk to Kevin?
Greiner:
Very good man.
Rener, Rener,
you made an offer.
She said yes to it.
‐Yeah, I like that.
Yeah, I like it.
I love it.
And, um, would you
be interested in having
someone else with you on
the deal at all...
No.
...or jumping in?
No. No need.
♪♪
‐I love it. We got a deal.
‐I can put some press‐‐
‐Whoo!
‐There you go.
[ Greiner laughs ]
I found my...
black‐belt
business Shark.
Ah, thank you.
[ Laughs ]
‐Congratulations.
‐Good stuff.
‐Congratulations, Rener.
‐Thank you so much, you guys.
Have a good one.
Whoo!
I went out there,
I turned on the "Renergy,"
and once I do,
there's no stopping it.
You can't turn it off.
They couldn't get a word in.
But they told me to own
the stage, and guess what I did.
That guy was
a ball of fire, man.
Force of nature.
Now that he's gone, we can
finally talk to each other.
[ Laughs ]
Narrator:
This season, we celebrated
10 years of "Shark Tank"...
[ Cork pops, cheering ]
There's only
one thing left to do.
...and our entrepreneurs
continue
to achieve their dreams.
Esnard: As an immigrant
from a developing country,
St. Lucia,
not having the opportunity
and just seeing
your product looking at you.
I love Daymond for that,
and thank you, "Shark Tank."
My dad
never gave up hope.
He fought so hard and kept
believing in miracles.
Kaley:
To be able to continue our dad's
dream is absolutely incredible
and to just share our story with
more people all over the world.
Welcome
to Tipsy Elves.
The Tipsy Elves story could only
happen in America.
We're two guys who quit
our successful careers
who now come into work
every day
designing amazing products
and putting smiles
on people's faces.
We just hit
$15 million in sales.
Carvana has just acquired
Car360 for $22 million.
We've just been acquired
for $34 million.
We've done over
$50 million in sales.
Isn't it amazing?
Martin:
Being a part of "Shark Tank"
is my "happily ever after."
I hope that it gives
inspiration to other moms
when they have a good idea
to go for it.
Narrator: And one entrepreneur
achieved the ultimate dream ‐‐
by becoming a Shark.
Siminoff:
"Shark Tank" is not just a show.
Kids are growing up, seeing what
entrepreneurs can do,
what inventors can do, and how
you can build your own destiny.
Narrator:
And we were inspired by other
exciting new guest Sharks.
Webb:
I feel like women and moms make
great business owners
because we're multi‐taskers.
I mean, women can handle a lot.
Hey!
Higgins: The entrepreneurs
who go on "Shark Tank,"
they're trying
to make it and transcend.
I relate to that. I feel like my
whole life has been about that.
Barkley: Entrepreneurship
is really important
because you give people power,
and I love when I give them
that power where they can
control their own destiny.
Narrator:
We strove to make a difference.
I think we need more women
wanting businesses,
and I think that starts
with each of you.
We'll be donating a portion of
proceeds to Dress for Success.
Woman: We all have been
struggling, broke,
and I want to show women,
you can achieve the impossible.
Houdashell:
We would like to donate $50,000
today to Make‐A‐Wish.
McGill:
Lori's deal was special because
she offered an opportunity
to give back ‐‐ a dollar
from each unit sold
to be given to a children's
charity of our choice.
My mission is
to make our military
the most efficient force
in the world.
It's amazing what kind of
innovation can come
while serving your country.
Now I have a thriving company
that's being backed by
the United States Air Force.
Narrator:
As we look towards the future...
[ Cheering ]
...we hope to continue
to inspire every generation
for decades to come.
Cuban:
The beauty of "Shark Tank"
is that anybody
can start a company.
Doesn't matter
where you grew up.
Doesn't really even matter
what kind of business.
It could be big or be small.
But you have a chance
to be on "Shark Tank,"
and who knows
what can happen from there?
All you have to do
is take that first step,
and anything is possible.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a product designed
to protect and intimidate.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Paul Mott,
and this is
my lovely wife, Pamela.
Hello, Sharks.
We're here from
San Diego, California,
seeking $250,000
for 10% of our company.
Now, Sharks, we all know there
are plenty of dog lovers
in the world, and it's easy
to understand why.
Because they bring so much
happiness to our lives.
But imagine you're out
with your sweet little dog
on a beautiful day,
and suddenly,
danger appears.
And before
you can do anything,
your dog
is gone forever.
That happened to us,
and I hate to say it,
it happens
all the time.
There are
so many coyotes,
aggressive dogs...
‐Oh.
‐Wow.
‐...and even birds of prey...
...that just want to take
our fur babies away.
We came up with a solution.
And we call it
CoyoteVest Pet Body Armor.
Come on, guys.
‐Oh! [ Laughs ]
‐[ Laughs ]
Scooter!
Come on.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
‐Come here, puppy!
‐Watch out!
‐That's Scooter.
‐You're a dog lover.
‐Aww. Look at him!
‐The stab‐resistant body armor
can slow down or prevent
a surprise attack
at any
given moment.
People love
CoyoteVest.
Just take a look at some
of our happy customers.
[ Laughter ]
And we have thousands
of amazing pictures.
‐Aww!
‐It keeps people from 'em, too.
So, which one of you Sharks
wants to help keep
our fur babies safe
and be part of a great
new American brand?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐That's great.
I do have some samples
I can pass around.
Let's see the samples. Yeah.
We're giving you
our original signature color.
‐Thank you.
‐For you.
Yes, you can take a look
at the materials
and notice how lightweight
it is.
So, Pamela, you had a puppy
that was snatched by a coyote?
Pamela: Yes, we did.
Her name was Buffy.
‐So what happened?
‐What happened to Buffy?
Herjavec: Like, you were
just walking along?
Paul: We were actually
at our local dog park,
and I heard a yelp,
and I turned around,
and I saw Buffy in
the jaws of a coyote...
‐Wow.
‐What?!
...being carried away
at full speed
up a hill
into heavy brush.
So I understand
the spikes here.
And these are,
like, metal spikes.
I mean, if something were
to bite into this,
it would puncture through
the roof of their mouth.
What happens is,
the moment the attacker
feels that sharp spike
against their mouth,
they just stop.
‐They stop.
The attack's over.
These coyote whiskers
are probably the most important
invention you see right here,
because what they do
is they introduce doubt
into the mind
of a predator.
Ahh.
The predator doesn't
know if these are
razor‐sharp,
poison‐tipped.
All he knows is, this does not
look like an easy meal.
What are your sales?
Since we started this company
2 1/2 years ago,
we've sold $570,000.
What have you sold
year‐to‐date this year?
Uh, this year, to date,
we've sold $260,000.
How do you sell it?
We sell directly
through our website.
What do you sell them for?
What do you make them for?
‐[ Dog whines ]
‐[ Laughs ]
‐[ Imitating dog yowling ]
‐We sell this kit,
as you see it,
for $120.
‐Ooh.
‐And it costs us $30 to make.
Cuban: Where do you make them?
How do you make them?
We make them right here
in the United States.
Good.
We actually have, uh,
set up our own
little miniature factory
to make these.
We've had to overcome quite
a few hurdles in our production.
You would think that people
would see this and say,
you know, "What is that?
I want one."
It's not blowing up because
people are saying...
[ Dog barks ]
..."Oh, it's for
a coyote attack only."
It's kind of for a very
specific niche‐y market.
But this is used for
more than just coyotes.
You could meet up with a dog,
and all of a sudden...
It's aggressive, yeah.
...and this even
happened to us,
they just
go for your dog.
What you need is
some batteries on this thing
so they light up and
you get an electric shock
when you bite it.
That's a great idea,
Mr. Wonderful.
‐Really?
‐What?
‐Let's see what we got.
‐He has a remote.
Well, we're gonna let somebody
come up and try it.
Scooter, hush.
‐Oh, I'll try it.
‐Yeah.
This is called
the CoyoteZapper...
[ Dog barks ]
...and it would've
saved Buffy's life.
Paul: So, just touch
a little bit there.
Grr.
Lightly, lightly.
Lightly, with
your fingertips.
[ High‐pitched ] Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Geez!
‐Was it bad?
Robert, can your screams
get any more high‐pitched?
[ Laughter ]
So, I'm interested, but my ‐‐ my
biggest concern is the factory.
Is your idea to operate
this factory yourself
or get to a point to scale
to get other factory
to do it, license it?
Where are you
with the factory?
Well, the only reason
we created a factory
is so that we could get
this company started
and make it through
the first couple of years.
Two challenges ‐‐ one Daymond
mentioned, and that's scaling.
‐We do have a manufacturer now.
‐We're ready to scale.
We are ready to scale.
Right, I know ‐‐
I know you're ready to,
but you haven't gone through
those problems yet.
And the second issue
is young children.
It's gonna be
a challenge for families
and the risk
that's involved there.
It's gonna take a lot
of hand‐holding
and personal attention
that I don't think
I'm quite
the right person to do.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
O'Leary: The problem is,
this is a small business,
and at $250,000 for 10%
is a $2.5 million valuation.
That ‐‐
‐This is patented, by the way.
Yeah, I get it.
But you actually
don't make any money yet,
even if you had $500,000,
'cause you have
to pay yourself something.
There's not a lot of room
for me as an investor.
It's not for me, guys.
I'm out.
‐Oh.
‐All right, well...
‐Thank you, Mr. Wonderful.
‐...thank you, Kevin.
I think
it looks fantastic
because it's funny,
it's fun, it's memorable.
So that's your greatest
advertising, right?
It's just ‐‐ I have
to feel like something
is going
to resonate for me,
and I just don't feel
strong enough about this.
So I'm out.
You know, 85% of
all businesses in America
are small business.
‐Mm‐hmm.
And most of
the new job growth
is being driven
by small business.
But not every business
needs an investment
or is investable yet.
I don't see
how, as an investor,
I can go on
the journey with you.
‐Okay.
‐I wish you all the best.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Not for me. I'm out.
‐We appreciate it.
‐All is not lost,
because we have a dog lover
here in Daymond.
[ Greiner laughs ]
Yeah, I just want
to make sure I get a chance
to address
Daymond's concerns.
We now have secured
a big manufacturer
who can deliver us
1,000 vests a month.
John: There's a level of
interest I have.
Uh‐huh.
But as of right now,
when you're just getting
from that positioning
of, you know,
running your own factory
to a new vendor
and you haven't gone
into large retail yet,
I think you're at
a very pivotal point...
We are.
...where it can
make or break you.
I just think it's a little risky
for me, so I'm out.
All right. Well, thank you
very much, Daymond.
We appreciate
the opportunity.
‐Bye. Good luck.
‐Bye‐bye.
‐Come on, Scoot.
‐Come on.
Paul: We're definitely gonna
keep moving forward
with this business.
There's a lot of dogs
out there in the world
that will need this product,
and we really want
to save their lives
as much as we can.
♪♪
It's been 10 years
since Mr. Wonderful
called us both
greedy pigs
on the first episode
of "Shark Tank."
Our company does
$100 million a year.
Thank you,
"Shark Tank."
Congratulations
on 10 seasons.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a way to attract
an often misunderstood creature.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Chris Rannefors.
And I'm
Harrison Broadhurst.
We're from
Lexington, Kentucky.
We're seeking
$100,000 for 16% of our company.
So, we have a problem.
With our winters
getting shorter and warmer,
insects like mosquitos
are coming out earlier
and in greater numbers,
bringing Zika and other
deadly diseases in their wake.
It seems like the only solutions
available on the marketplace
are expensive pesticides that
burn and irritate our skin
while also endangering
local wildlife.
And all of this while there's
been a perfect natural solution
that we never think of.
Both: Bats!
[ Gasps ]
So, most people don't know
that a common bat
will eat up to 1,000
mosquito‐sized insects
an hour...
‐What?
...making them one of
nature's greatest forms
of natural
pest control.
So how do we enlist
these amazing animals
to support our cause?
Introducing BatBnB.
‐Ta‐da!
‐That's right.
BnB as in a bed
and breakfast for bats.
[ Chuckles ]
Now, with our line
of designer bat houses,
you can
significantly reduce
your backyard
pest population.
Every BatBnB
is designed with
the animal's unique
lifestyle in mind,
with interior groove chambers
and landing pads
that allow the bat to easily
grip, climb, and hang.
‐The BatBnB ‐‐
‐Sounds like you, Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
The BatBnB
actually bio‐mimics
their natural habitat,
which is the space between
the peeling bark
on a dying tree.
And it also provides
an ideal environment
for mother bats to keep
their pups safe from predators.
With a BatBnB on your property,
whether it's your backyard,
your farm, or your business,
you can eliminate
swarms of harmful pests
while also providing
a much‐needed home
for a commonly
misunderstood animal.
Before we dive
into questions,
we know that there are a lot
of misconceptions around bats.
So we'd love for
you all to meet one.
‐No!
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Laughing ]
No, I don't want to.
At this point,
I'd love to invite
our trained
animal handler, Melinda,
to join us onstage...
‐Hello, Melinda.
...and introduce us
all to Radar.
‐Hi, Melinda.
‐Hi.
‐Where's the bat?
‐She's right here.
Oh, God, Melinda,
don't let it out.
‐Let it out!
‐Ohh.
‐Is it outside? It's inside.
‐You can't be afraid of that.
‐[ Chanting ] Free the bat.
‐So, this is Radar.
It's a 6‐year‐old rescue.
She had a damaged wing,
so that's why
she's in captivity.
Um, Radar's
a big brown bat.
They live all over Los Angeles
and all over North America.
They are
our target customer.
They hunt at night
when we're sleeping.
Hold on about
this hun‐‐ hunting at night.
When I was a teenager, I lived
in the city of Carthage...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Transylvania.
‐Oh, God.
‐...in Tunisia.
And they don't wait till night.
They come out at dusk.
‐Dusk.
‐And they blanket the sky.
Now, not every bat
eats mosquitos.
Some of them
enjoy blood.
‐[ Laughs evilly ]
‐They actually ‐‐
‐Your ‐‐ Your, uh, family.
‐Which is true.
And they actually
go hunt on mammals.
So, how do you know that
when you set up your BatBnB,
you're not getting
blood‐sucking bats?
Our target markets are
in the United States,
Canada,
Europe, and Australia,
primarily in the U. S. A.
right now.
Uh, vampire bats, there are
two species of them.
They live only in South
and Central America.
How are you guys
bat specialists?
Like, what's
your background?
Um, so, we're not
bat specialists.
So, we started this
back in 2016.
All the headlines were
Zika, Zika, Zika.
And Harrison and I were like,
"Oh, gosh, we want to have kids,
but we can't be
near Zika mosquitos."
And it was scary,
and we felt helpless.
So we looked at the market,
and like we said,
it's all pesticides,
and harmful pesticides.
So we drew on a childhood
experience I had
where I actually grew up
building bat houses
with my father.
Um, and we looked at ‐‐
You grew up building bat houses
with your father?
‐How did that come on?
‐How does that start?
Uh, my dad's
a big conservationist.
He's into animals.
‐There you go.
How many bats
could live in there?
Um, so, 80 to 100 bats
can fit in there.
‐Whoa!
‐80 to 100?!
I mean, you see ‐‐ you see
how little, uh, Radar is, here.
‐So they like to be close?
‐Yeah.
Herjavec: But, Chris,
people don't like bats.
Like, it freaks
most people out.
How do you sell this to people
and educate them?
So, you're absolutely right,
Robert.
So, ever since Bram Stoker
wrote "Dracula,"
like, over 100 years ago,
bats had to suffer
from the big, bad wolves.
‐They're scary‐looking, though?
O'Leary: It's as far back
as Greek mythology.
They were considered
to live in Hades.
Persephone
was very involved.
Also, in Rome, it was ‐‐ If you
didn't want to go to sleep,
you cut
the head off a bat
and put it in a bag
by your left arm.
‐Yeah.
‐[ Laughs ]
It goes
further back.
Yes.
I am one with the bat.
Yes, I know.
They're your relatives.
No, no.
I just understand them.
So, tell us
about your business.
So, we launched via crowdfunding
about 11 months ago.
So far, our revenues to date
have been $135,000.
And what are you projecting
sales will be for this year?
So, sales for this year,
we're looking at
$145,000 this year.
Chris, how big
is this market?
So, while we've been growing
on the consumer side,
where we see the high growth
in this market,
uh, is in the public
sector.
So, if you look at the public
sector, on the county level,
there are enormous budgets
for mosquito and pest control.
What does it cost you
to make it?
Yeah, it costs $88.50
for us to make it.
It costs $239
with shipping.
Herjavec: Wow.
Harrison, Chris,
I see it as a hobby market.
It's relatively small.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
Appreciate that.
Cuban: How do you get, um,
a city, county, state ‐‐
whatever it may be ‐‐
how do you get to them?
Yeah, so that‐‐ that's part
of ‐‐ That's one tier
of what we would do
with an investment.
We'd pursue relationships,
and we would work with people
who have experience in ‐‐
So, let's just say
that goes perfectly.
Where do
your sales go?
So, we've done
a five‐year forecast,
and in Year 5, we'll be
a $1 million‐a‐year business.
Honestly, I just don't see
that being big enough,
right, for the amount of time
and work that's involved.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
John: I have a lot of bats
on my property.
It hasn't really reduced,
as far as I know, uh,
much of
the mosquito issue.
I still feel like
I have a mosquito problem
or a bug problem,
and I just don't think
that people understand the value
of what you're doing.
And I just think it's a hard way
to educate people.
So, with that, I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
And then
there were two.
♪♪
Greiner: Um, it's just not
the product for me.
I can't even ‐‐ Like,
I'm sitting here going "eww"
every second, 'cause just
the bat thing for me,
I just ‐‐ I can't
invest in it.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
That's okay.
I, on the other hand,
have a lot of passion
for bats,
because they're so
misunderstood over the ages.
Here comes
the blood‐sucking offer.
There's no blood‐sucking
involved here.
This is
a fruit‐bat offer, okay?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐Here's the way I look at it.
I like it.
It's a small market.
It needs a tremendous
amount of promotion
and someone
has to explain it.
And nobody knows
more about bats than I do.
So I'll give you
the 100K for 33.3%.
♪♪
That's the only deal
I'll consider.
Sorry, that ‐‐ that's
a little too low for us.
Um, if you're willing
to do 25%,
we're willing
to do it.
I have to feel that I've got
a seat at the table.
I think it's a lot of hard work
in a very small market.
But I can bring so much
promotion to it.
And I don't have a bat cave
in my portfolio...
[ Laughter ]
...so I'm thinking
of adding it now.
But it's got to be at 33.3.
You have a deal.
[ Chuckles ]
Thank you, Kevin.
Thank you so much for
your offer, by the way.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
[ Chuckles ]
Ask him.
[ Laughs ]
Will you put on a Batman suit
if we ‐‐ if we ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
‐Done.
‐It's a deal.
‐Oh, I didn't see that coming.
‐I love it.
Nice to meet you guys.
‐Appreciate it.
‐That's a hell of
a great presentation.
‐Oh, my God.
Very good.
Who more perfect
for a bat house?
‐Kevin, turn into a bat!
‐Thank you, everybody.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Thank you.
♪♪
Rannefors:
Two years ago, when we first
started this, it was a little ‐‐
a little hobby thing
that Harrison and I did
in our ‐‐
in our free time.
And now we got Kevin on board
with all of his resources
and finances and the ‐‐
and the investment?
Like, there's no place
we can't go.
Like, it's ‐‐
it's fantastic.
You know, in the Mayan culture,
way back when,
bats started getting
a bad rap so far ago
because people
were scared of them.
Were you around during
the Mayan culture?
I first became close
with them in Tunisia.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐That's where it started.
Is that when you started
sleeping upside down?
Yes, when I
first met the bats.
I also met them in
Addis Ababa in Ethiopia.
At night, they would
cover the skies.
I would say to my father,
"What are those, Dad?"
And he'd say,
"Those are bats."
‐[ Laughs ]
‐"Those are our relatives!"
‐And I always thought, one day,
I would be
in the bat business.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a business
that does not skimp
on the good stuff.
♪♪
What's up, guys?
I'm Tom Armenti.
And I'm Kevin Gabauer, and we're
from Fort Collins, Colorado.
We're seeking
a $250,000 investment
for a 7.5% stake
in our company.
Sharks, picture
the perfect healthy meal ‐‐
flakes of seaweed,
sautéed in coconut oil,
sprinkled
with chia seeds,
all resting on a bed
of crisp green kale.
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐At our restaurant,
we specialize in taking
this perfectly healthy meal...
...and throwing it
right in the trash!
[ Laughter ]
We're the Fat Shack.
‐Ahh.
‐Ohh.
‐Oh, my God.
O'Leary: Oh, yeah.
Not only do we serve
your favorite foods ‐‐
like French fries,
chicken fingers,
and mozzarella sticks ‐‐
but we do it all
on one sandwich.
‐No!
‐Yes!
We're gonna start here
with your French fries
and your cheesesteak,
then we're gonna load it up
with some chicken fingers...
‐Oh, oh...
...followed by some
mozzarella sticks on there...
‐Oh, my God.
‐...and then some onion rings.
Hm. It's still looking
a little bit light.
What do you think, Kev?
‐Jalapeño poppers!
Of course!
We've got jalapeño poppers.
‐Why not?
‐Throw those jalapeño poppers,
and then we
finish it off
with tons and tons
of our ooey...
[ Laughter ]
...gooey sauce.
Now, we're gonna wrap
this thing up nice and tight
so we can serve it just
like a normal sandwich.
‐Oh.
‐Now, that is what we call..
the perfect meal.
‐Now, Sharks, we have plenty
of other normal‐people
food, as well ‐‐
triple‐stacked
cheeseburgers...
[ Cuban laughs ]
...deep‐fried
funnel cake bites.
And the best part
is we're open as late
as 4:00 A. M.
We have seen huge success
with our concept,
and we're committed
to making our growth
even bigger
than our sandwiches.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to dig in
and join
the Fat Shack team?
‐Got to try it.
‐We got some samples ‐‐
some kale salad
for you guys.
No. I'm just kidding
[ Laughter ]
‐"Fat Shack."
‐[ Chuckles ]
How did he get that sandwich
to look like that?
How many calories
in that sandwich?
Armenti: We have small ones that
range from, like, 700 to 800,
and then bigger ones
that get up to 2,000.
‐That one's for you, Robert.
‐Only 2,000?
2,000 calories.
A full day.
Thank you so much.
‐For Mr. Wonderful.
‐You have any forks?
‐And then here's for you, Mark,
the Fat Jersey.
Herjavec: This is not a fork
kind of meal, Lori.
Greiner: Oh, my God, oh, my God.
What is in here?
‐It is good, though.
‐Mmm.
‐What's in mine?
‐Lori, you have the Fat Tommy.
That's French fries, chicken
fingers, lettuce, tomato,
pickles, and ketchup, mayo.
‐In the sandwich?
‐All on the sandwich, yes.
‐On the sandwich.
‐Robert, you have the Fat Slob.
‐I feel the big one!
I feel the big one coming!
‐That one's French fries,
chicken fingers,
cheesesteak,
mozzarella sticks,
ketchup, mayo.
Wow.
Mr. Wonderful,
the Fat Donkeylips.
[ Chuckles ] You got
French fries, chicken fingers,
lettuce, Buffalo,
and blue cheese.
Daymond, the Fat Chance.
‐Oh, my God.
Cheesesteak,
jalapeño poppers,
chicken fingers,
French fries, Buffalo ranch.
And then, Mark,
the Fat Jersey ‐‐
French fries,
cheesesteak,
mozzarella sticks...
‐This is incredible.
...chicken fingers,
and house‐made honey
mustard all on it.
I never thought it would
just taste that good, though.
That is nasty,
nasty, nasty good.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I'm glad you like it.
‐Wow.
‐It's incredible.
Herjavec: Tom, how did you
come up with this?
Armenti: So, I'm actually
the founder of Fat Shack.
I started it back
in February of 2010.
Uh, Kevin and I know each other
going way back.
We went to college together.
But all throughout college,
I never had a job.
I've actually never really
had a job my whole life,
and I played online poker
through school
just to make money
and, you know...
‐You're kidding.
‐...support myself.
I just knew I needed
to do something different.
So, when I graduated
from school,
I found a local bagel shop
that was near the school.
And he closed his doors
at 3:00 P. M.,
and I was able to negotiate
a deal with him
where I would come in
and run my restaurant
using his equipment
from 6:00 at night
until 4:00 in the morning.
‐Come on.
So I was able to open
the whole concept
back in Jersey for less ‐‐
‐The Fat is born.
[ Laughter ]
For less ‐‐
Herjavec: I have never heard
of that kind of story.
Yeah, I was able to open
for less than $5,000,
so that's how it all started.
‐Very smart.
You're a hustler.
And I have family
that lives in Colorado
where Colorado
State University ‐‐
CSU ‐‐ is. And that's when
I moved out to Colorado,
opened the first
full Fat Shack.
So, how many locations
do you guys have now?
Right now we have a total of 11
in 3 different states.
And these are all ‐‐
You own these locations,
or are any of them franchised?
So, 9 of them are
franchisees of ours,
and then Tom and I
own two ‐‐
two of the other stores.
‐Wow.
So, tell us the numbers,
overall sales.
Cool. So, sales to date since
we started back in 2010
have been just over
$22 million.
‐Whoa.
‐What?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, we sold $22 million
of Fat Shack product...
‐What about last year?
‐...in the last eight years.
So ‐‐ So last year,
we did about $5.7 million
in system‐wide sales.
So, what's your franchise fee?
What's your advertising hit?
Yep. So, our franchise fee
is $18,000.
‐Okay.
‐And then we have a 6% royalty
that we take
every ‐‐ every week.
And what about
advertising?
Uh, advertising,
as of right now,
we do not have one.
‐Okay.
What are your revenues,
profits, et cetera?
So, basically,
any given store,
we have an average
revenue per year
is gonna be between
$40,000 and $45,000,
uh, that we'll get
from those royalties.
And of course, we'll have
the $18,000 up front.
Um, we did $300,000
last year,
and the profit on that
was just about $170,000.
This year, we'll do about
$425,000 to $450,000
in revenue just
with the franchising.
So, really, for us
to make our money back,
we got to open up
a lot of franchises.
For sure.
Yeah. And that's our plan.
How's your worst‐performing
franchise doing?
They're still profitable,
our worst‐performing store.
Like, in terms of revenue
and profitability.
In terms of revenue,
they'll probably
do about $500,000.
How much do they make
on the $500,000?
So, they'll probably make
about 10% on average
is what our profit margin is...
‐$50,000.
...for the franchises
themselves.
Are they kids? Are they
university students?
Like, what's
the average ‐‐
So, we've
specifically worked
with people
that are younger,
and a lot of them have actually
come up through our system.
So, over half
of our franchisees
started off working
for me directly...
‐That's great.
‐...as a delivery driver.
So, what does it cost
to open up a new unit?
So, we've opened most of
the units that we have right now
between $75,000 and
$100,000, start to finish.
‐Do you fund it?
‐So, there's a few that we have.
So, like Tom says, if there's
an employee that we have
that started out
as a delivery driver,
worked their way up
the ladder,
we have funded a few of
those stores, um, for them.
So, you're only offering 7.5%
of basically $140,000 after tax
you can distribute.
Think about me as an investor.
I could take the $250,000,
put it into a REIT,
making me 9% that has
tremendous distribution
or give it to you
with the risk
that you somehow
stumble on the rollout.
So ‐‐
It's not that attractive.
You're not ‐‐
Yeah, so, right now,
we have five stores
that are basically
ready to go.
A couple of the guys,
you know, are waiting ‐‐
are waiting
for funding from us.
But isn't it more efficient
for you guys
to get multi‐unit
operators?
‐For sure.
‐It definitely helps, yeah.
I mean ‐‐ So, is the plan just
to, like, grow organically
and, you know,
enable your employees,
or are you looking for
somebody to come along and say,
"I'll open 10 units"?
So, our growth strategy
isn't all just employees.
It definitely is finding people
from the outside, as well.
But right now, we are looking
for those owner/operators.
We want to find
those grinders
that were like myself
in the very beginning.
You guys are incredible. I mean,
your whole story is amazing.
But there isn't
that much money in it.
I mean,
I get the $22 million.
But we're talking about
$150,000 after tax.
So, when we get these
next five stores open,
that will bring us up
to about $700,000 in revenue
and about
a $400,000 profit.
I give you
$250,000, 7.5%,
I'm getting about
30 grand a year.
I'm assuming
you're doing a distribution.
‐Yeah, definitely.
‐So I'm getting 30 grand,
which is 12% interest
on my $250,000.
It's interesting,
but, you know,
you don't get to be a Shark by
making interest along the way.
‐Yeah, for sure.
‐How do I get that $250,000
to be $2 million?
Is it just more locations?
Yeah. Our goal is
to increase, you know,
the footprint across
the country.
We've definitely
proven the model.
But we're building this
into a corporation
that will be here
for the next 60 years.
I have no intention of
going anywhere with this.
Look. I'll make you
an offer commensurate
with my perception
of your risk, okay?
‐Uh, oh.
‐My perception of your risk.
‐Let's hear it.
‐Here's his blood‐sucking offer.
Right now, I don't hear
any other offers, so...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐...I'd be smiling and saying,
"Thank you, Mr. Wonderful,
for making any offer."
There's a smile.
[ Laughter ]
I'll give you
the $250,000.
I want 25%.
Wow.
You know, don't bite
the hand that feeds you.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Tom and Kevin have an offer
on the table from Kevin O'Leary
for their decadent fast‐food
business, Fat Shack.
I'll give you the $250,000.
I want 25%.
♪♪
Wow.
You know, don't bite
the hand that feeds you.
You know what that gets me?
About a 14% return,
assuming there's delays
on the release
of the new stores,
which I think will happen.
And we appreciate
that offer, definitely.
I think Kevin was
looking at my notes.
I have the same offer ‐‐
$250,000 for 25%.
Appreciate that.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you, Daymond.
We appreciate the offer.
Herjavec: Why are you taking
any of the distribution out?
That's how the franchise
model works, Robert.
No, no, I know.
But at this point,
wouldn't it be better just
to leave the money in there
for a number of years
and grow it?
So, and that's what
we've essentially done,
is Kevin and I have
only really pulled out
what we need to ‐‐
But going forward, you're
gonna start distributing it.
Going forward, if you guys
agree to a 7.5%,
we're happy to pay
your distribution out
every single year.
‐It doesn't work at 7.5%.
You're giving me less ‐‐
‐I understand, I understand.
I'm just saying, we're happy
to pay that distribution out,
and we're happy
to keep grinding it out...
For sure.
...and putting our money
back into people.
You know, I think you have
other Sharks interested,
and I don't feel strong
enough about it to compete.
So I'm out.
We appreciate it,
yeah.
Kevin, I‐I like it.
Here's my offer on it.
There's no need
for you in this, Robert.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐I really, really like it.
But you can't give up 25%.
‐No.
‐Correct.
I mean, that sucks
the life out of you.
Let's hear the offer.
‐Like, why would you do that?
‐Right.
‐I'll give you $250,000 for...
17%.
‐We appreciate that offer.
‐Um...
I don't want to take
any money out, though.
‐That's crazy. That's crazy.
‐Like, I don't want to take
any distribution until
we get to a certain point.
For me, there's no point in
taking out distribution
for the next five years.
‐Yeah.
Like, what? What, am I gonna get
interest on my $250,000?
We appreciate
you seeing that angle.
Let's go.
Cuban: The business side
of me says
you're hitting
every line item, right?
What I can't
get past is,
just the whole
health thing, right?
Every other
food product I have
is geared towards
healthy living.
Herjavec: This is why
you need to balance ‐‐
Well, it's time
to mix up the portfolio.
Gabauer:
Yeah, let's get a little bit
of diversification.
You know, we don't eat Fat Shack
every single day, obviously.
It's a cheat meal
for people...
Yeah, you guys
are in good shape.
...to come in and
get something really good.
Thank you.
And knowing that we can make
our good money on that?
It really is
an awesome concept...
Herjavec: What are you
gonna do, Mark?
...and customers
just go nuts for it.
O'Leary:
You in or out?
All right,
I'll offer you 250K,
but I want the 17%
that Robert's offering,
and the reason
is that much,
because it's ‐‐
it's a slow burn.
And the real home run in all
this isn't the franchise fee.
‐So it's an exit, right?
‐Yeah.
And the challenge is that
it's gonna take a lot of years.
That's the ‐‐ the catch‐22.
There's got to be enough upside
for all that I'd be investing.
John: I'll bring mine down
to 17%, as well.
Greiner: Wow.
Okay, guys.
‐We would do a deal ‐‐
We would do a deal at 12%.
‐Oh, that's not exciting.
‐It's not enough.
‐Okay, guys. It's decision time.
[ Indistinct whispering ]
Yeah, we could
do that. Yeah,
So...
Mark, would you
be willing to do
$250,000 for 15%
of the company?
♪♪
‐15%?
‐We'd call it right now. 15%.
‐Done.
‐Done deal.
‐Great.
‐Let's do it.
‐Let's go get fat!
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Applause ]
Cuban: All right, appreciate it.
Appreciate it.
‐Thank you, Mark.
‐Good job, baby.
‐Oh, let's eat!
‐Oh, yeah.
‐Ahh!
‐You want a bite?
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Greiner laughs ]
Armenti: So, I started
this company for under $5,000
running out of a garage
and countless of hours
in the kitchen.
And then here we are now
with this deal with Mark Cuban.
So all these 8 years of grinding
it out has truly paid off.
♪♪